[ __ ]
I know your secrets I know about your
friends
[Music]
Jessica
I know everything
hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my Jessica Jones trailer
breakdown there's much new footage we
finally got some purple man and we see
Trish Walker she's you've been in some
promo we haven't seen her in a trailer
yet there's also a lot of rumors going
around about the Inhumans movie maybe
being cancelled in phase 3 because of
all the extra stuff they've been
shuffling around so I'll just clarify
what's going on with that after the
trailer stuff here we go Jessica Jones
the first part of the clip just picks up
later in the night from the last trailer
that I posted she had just gotten done
being the [ __ ] out of all those people
in that bar and now she's walking down
this street she's going back to her
office at alias investigations the ad on
the street sign over here for Trish talk
that's Trish Walker from the comic her
superhero name is Hellcat but like a lot
of daredevil characters even though
she's someone from the comics I think
they're changing her just a little bit
she might not be Hellcat on this TV show
the problem with Hellcat is that like
some of her backstory gets tied up with
the x-men in hate McCoy and as cool as
it is there's no way they can do any
kind of x-men stuff right now
which also kind of dovetails nicely with
this next a little bit in the trailer
everyone's asking did she jump onto that
fire escape or did she fly and I think
that she just jumped my understanding is
is that they're not gonna let her fly
during the series just to keep her from
being overpowered so think like a
slightly tuned down version of Golden
Age Superman leaping tall buildings
except no heat vision then later in the
night we see her inside her office just
putting up pictures on her evidence
board it's kind of hard to make out some
of these pictures but here's another
picture of Trish Walker so she might be
doing a case for Trish Walker purple man
might be going after it because you kind
of hear the David Tennant voiceover you
know where it's like I know all your
secrets I know who your friends are
Trish Walker is one of her friends so he
might be targeting people close to her
this could also be from like some other
random case that she's working just like
daredevil season 1 was all about that
one legal case with Karen Paige I'm
guessing Jessica Jones is also gonna
follow that model as then she'll have
like one really big case that she's
investigating that will get bigger and
bigger and start involving more and more
characters like when daredevil first
started investigating Karen page he
didn't know anything about kingpin or
his involvement so I'm getting I'm
guessing it's gonna spiral out the same
way with Jessica Jones investigations
the actual title of that first episode
is called ladies night so it sounds like
she's gonna be beating the [ __ ] out of a
lot of people in a bar which sounds like
a lot of fun so we've just gotten a
taste of the purple man I'm kind of
wondering what they've done with his
powers too
because very clearly his skin is not
gonna be purple but he has a certain
level of resilience Jessica Jones was
super strong so we might see her beat
the [ __ ] out of him and him just eat it
him just soak it up he's not telepathic
but he can give people visions with his
pheromones like he exudes pheromones
that gives him a low level of control
over people it's like a biochemical
thing so there's a lasting effect even
when he's not in proximity to you so in
this scene here when she's hallucinating
him speaking those are just his
pheromones still in her bloodstream
moving into movie territory I know
everyone's freaking out about Inhumans
stuff just because it may have gotten
kicked off the schedule there's a lot of
talk about politics behind the scenes at
Marvel I don't know anything about that
it's so far off like the movie itself
was so far off initially that its status
is pretty fluid you know I think that
they wouldn't hesitate smooth around if
something more pressing came along like
if a sequel came along they needed to do
the person who helped rewrite ant-man
Adam McKay expressed an interest in
doing Inhumans in there ramping up on
agents of shield so even if things don't
work out with the movie like Adam McKay
doesn't end up writing it or someone
else then don't automatically assume
that they'll be able to do the royal
family on the TV show I always feel like
the royal family is gonna be big enough
that they'll hold them for the movies
so just officially on paper Marvel has
not cancelled the Inhumans yet it just
talked about what's going on behind the
scenes about you know them maybe not
doing it maybe doing it no one has been
hired to do anything for it yet they
even just confirmed that they haven't
started writing the Captain Marvel movie
yet because they feel like she's super
overpowered so they're still trying to
figure out what are her weaknesses gonna
be like what are her vulnerabilities
there's like too many character problems
they have to work through before they
can actually write a story so that's
just what's going on with Phase three
but the cool thing they - is that they
talked about Madame masque at New York
Comic Con on agent Carter
agent Carter for those who don't know is
gonna premiere next January just like it
did last year same deal same drill
they're gonna have way more comic book
characters though so if you feel like
agent Carter season one was kind of
comic book light then season two is
gonna be way more fun but coming up next
I'm working on another flash arrow video
with some new footage so be sure to
subscribe to get that I'll try to post
that before dr. justo
tomorrow so that it should be like an
early video there is lots of cool stuff
happening at New York Comic Con this
weekend if there's anything like really
really cool then I'll totally upload it
to my channel I just posted the Game of
Thrones panel you can actually you can
click here to watch that game of Thrones
balance the whole thing and you can
click here for all my other agents of
shield Marvel videos thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you